[MUSIC PLAYING]
Should I juggle a bit?
Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've had a long-term
love affair with lemons.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHS]
This is a world of colors,
intensity, condiments, tahini,
hummus, muhummara,
everything together.
So it's totally informal, the
opposite of French cooking,
right?
See this beautiful smoke?
That's all flavor.
The one thing I really
don't like is a boring meal.
They want to go,
ah, what was that?
People think, I can't
cook Middle Eastern.
I don't know how to make my
vegetables taste delicious.
I hope to show you that
you can cook those things,
and you can do it
really, really well.
Vegetables have an
incredible ability
to be played with, manipulated
a bit, soak flavors, grilled.
These carrots-- is
very Instagrammable.
This is a very crucial moment.
When you add ice water,
it aerates the hummus,
makes it even smoother, lighter.
And I'm adding confit garlic.
I can't possibly envisage
a dish without garlic.
That's just not natural.
[LAUGHS]
Eggplants take on flavors
like nothing else.
There's something
meaty about them.
This dish-- it
happens to be vegan.
I challenge any meat eater
to say it's not perfect.
I always like to keep
the last bit for myself.
I grew up in the heart
of the Middle East,
where there's quite a lot
of confrontation going on.
And I found, over the
years, that food is really
an international language.
It has this incredible ability
to bring people together.
I want you to be able to go into
the kitchen without the stress.
I want you to be able
to sit around a table,
share a meal with your
family and friends,
and be really proud of
what you've created.
I'm Yotam Ottolenghi, and
this is my MasterClass.